[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
terror
this week i wanted to talk about a book
that i had seen recommended on a whole
bunch of different
booktubers channels that i had been
watching looking for recommendations
and when i first got interested in
reading it and
ordered it off amazon i didn't actually
realize that this book is actually quite
old
the first publication was 1981 and
it got reissued in 2014
i also didn't realize that the author
michael mcdowell
had quite a pedigree had written a lot
of books
um in the early 80s like during the kind
of golden age of
paperback uh horror fiction where you
know there were really a lot of good uh
authors publishing
and also he wrote the original
screenplay
for beetlejuice and also for the
nightmare before christmas i believe so
this is a guy that you know should have
been on my radar and sadly was not but
i guess that's been rectified now sadly
uh many years after he passed away i
believe he passed away in
1999. so the book that i want to talk
about this is the first
one of his that i've ever read is called
the elementals now this
is a southern gothic
horror and so know that going into it
it's very
uh tennessee williams very flannery
o'connor
like that kind of vibe except
maybe more overtly horror although it
doesn't get really really overtly
like scary and with horrific images and
stuff until the end
um as i said on my previous videos i'm
not i'm gonna try not to spoil too much
of anything but it's kind of hard to
talk about a book if you can't talk
about some aspects of it that may seem
spoilery
so if you want to come into this book
completely blind
which i would suggest actually then
maybe like turn this off go read it it's
not very long it's only about 200 pages
then then none of the big like surprises
or anything like that will be spoiled
for you
now this interesting this interestingly
this
reissue uh came out in 2014 i guess
vandencourt books the publisher
they've been publishing like a lot of
fiction from that era like they're kind
of plucking out a lot of the you know
paperback
horror uh that came out around that time
like kind of the best examples of it and
are reissuing it
with you know nice uh you know
introductions and new covers and all
this other kind of stuff which is really
cool and i'm really glad that they're
doing that because
so much horror fiction came out like in
the late 70s and early 80s
and there was a lot of good stuff but
you know just like when there's a glut
of anything there was a lot of bad stuff
too so it's nice to have
this kind of curated i guess these
authors and all these stories that they
thought were like worthy of like
publication
now this one like i said michael
mcdowell was actually
and it says right here on the cover uh
one of the finest
writers of paperback fiction and that's
a quote from stephen king
you know like i said this is this is
very southern gothic so
i guess michael mcdowell is from alabama
and this story is set in alabama i guess
um i've heard that all of his
you know stories are not but this one
definitely is and i feel like
you know the atmosphere you know the
alabamaness of this story is like really
a big part of its appeal
um because i feel like the place becomes
pretty much its own character like you
know the way this
this really weird place where most of
the story takes place
and you know just this bizarre like gulf
coast
island essentially with like all this
sand and stuff but it's really really
crazy
so the story is there are these two
southern families uh the mccrays and the
savages and i believe they're um
related by marriage they're also like
all friends with each other i guess
they're kind of
old money like from mobile alabama they
own like big businesses and everything
so they live in these two kind of
mansions in mobile which is where they
run their businesses
but there's also these vacation homes
that they have
in this place called beldom i guess is
how you would pronounce it
and it's on the gulf coast of alabama
and it's basically like this little
like slip of beach like a little slip of
land
and it has three identical victorian
houses on it now one of the houses
is owned by the savage family one of the
houses is owned by
the mccray family the third house which
is how it's referred to through the
entire story
apparently either no one owns it or no
one knows who owns it
but as the story goes on you discover
that everyone is
afraid of the third house but they won't
really say why
so when the story opens like in the
prologue
the kind of matriarch of the savage
family
marion savage she has died
so basically the opening scene is like
her funeral
so you know during the course of this
funeral you get like all this extended
family and they're all like really
southern eccentric like type of
characters
they're it's really weird because
they're realistic
but then not realistic at the same time
if that makes any sense
like i grew up in the south not alabama
but i grew up in florida
and um a lot of my relatives were like
from tennessee and from other southern
states
so it's like i don't really think i mean
from my point of view these characters
not really that much of an exaggeration
you know my parents weren't like old you
know my family wasn't like old money or
anything like that so i'm sure that has
their own
a whole other set of eccentricities to
go along with it but
it is kind of overdone for like a kind
of comedic effect because this almost
has
almost a little bit of a black comedy
kind of vibe to it at least in the
beginning like because i feel like in
the end it kind of
goes in a horrific direction but so
there's a funeral
for marion savage who is apparently you
don't meet her like in the course of the
book because she's already dead
but from what other people say about her
you know you get the impression that she
was
kind of horrible and that she was just
like this you know overbearing like kind
of
mean you know woman so they're all at
the funeral
and then there's this really weird
ritual
that apparently they have at every every
time
one member of this family dies you know
somebody has to do this
like at the funeral i'm not gonna say
what it is cause i was just like reading
going what the [ __ ] is
going on it's like they explain why
later on
but it's like i just love how the book
even from the prologue
it just kind of immerses you in this
bizarre
you know these kind of bizarre rituals
and these like really weird like quirky
southern characters this like weird
family but the family are not like
they're not off-puttingly weird they're
like you know you can get into
the characters and their interactions
with each other their dialogues are like
very funny
so after the funeral they all decide um
that they're going to
take kind of like a vacation or take a
break um you know to kind of get away
from
the homestead you know where marion
lived and everything
so it's like so we're gonna go to to
beldum
and uh stay at the houses like over the
summer now
many of the uh relatives and you know
relations of this family have been
staying at this
place since they were kids like you know
they would go there every summer it was
kind of a tradition
and the weird thing about the place is
that you kind of forget about it when
you're not there but
then it's like when you get there it's
like it's scary kind of and creepy and
oppressive and weird but then like you
don't want to leave
it's almost like this weird like
hypnotic spell that it has over you kind
of
it's like they don't go super into that
but that's kind of like a background
uh thing that's going on so now we're
mostly seeing this is
it's um you know it's written like kind
of uh
you know it's just narrated it's not
like inside anyone's head or anything
like that
but mostly you're getting the
perspective
of one of the sons one of the mcrae sons
luker and he has a 13 year old daughter
named
india now they he grew up in
in alabama and he had been to beldon as
a kid but
when he got older like he moved to new
york city so
india i don't think i mean she's only 13
and her mom has taken off and they talk
about how much she sucks and everything
like that
she doesn't really figure into the story
all that much so india i don't believe
has ever been
to alabama she's for sure never been to
beldon because she is like fascinated by
it when she gets there
so she's never been to alabama she's
only known new york city
and she's very even though she's only 13
she's very
precocious and i think one of the
funniest things about
this book is that india
and luker are their father and daughter
and you can tell that they are very fond
of each other and they love each other
and everything
but their interactions with each other
are just very very funny they're almost
like
the same age friends like you know luke
they make like no bones at all about him
taking
speed or whatever and him i don't know
if he ever gave her any but he doesn't
hide it from her
and it's like she knows about all his
pills and you know if she's upset he'll
give her some scotch or something like
that
and they like swear at each other so
they seem almost like the same age
rather than father and daughter but not
in a weird way like it actually works
out and i think like the relationship
between the two of them
is one of the best things in the book
and
india and um michael rowe who wrote the
um
you know what do you call it the
introduction for this edition
uh he wrote enter knight i believe among
other things he
uh compared india he's like you can see
in her character
the seeds of lydia deets from
beetlejuice and you definitely can
because this is the same
even though she's a bit younger than
lydia was
but she's very snarky she's very you
know sophisticated because she grew up
in the city and now she's like in this
podunk
like place in alabama but she's kind of
fascinated by it too
plus she's like very into photography
and stuff so and she's
also kind of fascinated with morbid
things and
even when weird [ __ ] starts to happen at
the houses
she doesn't it's almost kind of like she
believes it but not
a lot of the um you know the [ __ ] in the
book is kind of from her point of view
so it's almost a little bit from an
outsider perspective
because most of the other people in the
family have been to beldon before
so they're kind of a little bit more
familiar with it so
they get down there now it turns out
like i said the two houses that are
owned by the families
so they each stay in their respective
houses but the third house
which like i said they don't really know
who owns it and that's the only way they
refer to it
nobody lives in there and hasn't for a
very long time
and it's being slowly consumed
by sand so
when they get there like after the
funeral
that there's basically like a dune that
is like
kind of covering most of the house and
the only way that you can look in some
of the upper windows is to basically
like climb up the dune
and like look in there so of course
india ends up doing that
and she sees something
now as i said this is a very
i want to call it literary horror
because like i said it's a little more
on the literary side than kind of more
on the pulp side
and there's just something really
unsettling and like hypnotic about it
it takes a while to get going even
though it's quite short
it's just like there's all this
character development and stuff and
things just happen very very slowly
it's like but you can picture in your
head
like them being in alabama on the gulf
coast
in the summer and it's just oppressively
hot
and um the way he describes it is like
very very accurate because like i said
florida so you know it's
i know all about the humidity and
everything and the way he described it
was like really
made you feel it so you really kind of
feel like you're there and then just
this really
unsettling image of being in these two
big victorian houses
and looking out the window and seeing a
third one that just that just a sand
dune is like slowly overtaking it
and so that's kind of like creepy enough
but then as it goes on
you know there's just little things that
start to happen like
india climbs up the dune and like looks
in the
you know looks in the window of one of
the upper floors and she sees a door
close even though no one's supposed to
be in there and
then she sees other things like kind of
sand coming in there and like forming
into things and like
stuff like that starts to happen and
then kind of
so it goes on for a long time like that
and then like the last
probably quarter of the book it just
goes batshit crazy like all the stuff
that they're
seeing in there and you get to find out
i don't want to say you get to find out
exactly what's going on in the house
because
it's left kind of ambiguous like they
sort of explain it but sort of not
but in a way i kind of like that they
left it ambiguous because it's like
this is like a haunted house story but
it's not really ghosts you know what i
mean it's not like ghosts
in the traditional sense of like oh it's
a dead person that's
you know rattling around in there it's
not even like a poltergeist type of
thing
it's something different um
and if you know what an elemental is um
then you'll get kind of the gist but one
thing that i did like about that was
that because these were
a different kind of spirit or a
different kind of monster or different
kind of you know antagonist or whatever
you want to call it
you didn't really know what the rules
were
like you didn't know how to get rid of
it you didn't know it was going to work
on it
and they kind of go into this a lot
because one of the characters
odessa red who is actually their um
african-american maid has been with like
the family for a very long time
and she kind of knows what the things
are
and she kind of knows like some things
that might stop them or some
but even she admits to india later on
she's like well
you know they're not ghosts and there's
not like any rules so it's like
something that work on
works on them today like to fight them
off might not work on them tomorrow
because they're just constantly [ __ ]
with you
so in a way that was good because it
made it more
i guess it makes it more scary in a way
because you don't really know like
there's nothing really that you can do
about it because you're not really sure
what they are or what they can do or you
know if there's anything you can do
against them or if you're just [ __ ] or
whatever
so i liked that aspect of it a lot like
i said i think the only thing
i don't know i i don't know if i would
call this a criticism necessarily
because it didn't really bother me when
i was reading it but it does like i said
it does
seem like it kind of goes on and it's
not slow
but it's you know it's just very
deliberate like the way it's built up
and it's just like a little thing and a
little thing and a little thing and it's
just like kind of these really
unsettling images
but then it doesn't start getting like
horrific
until almost the end so it almost kind
of seems like
i don't want to say like the ending
sound seems rushed because it doesn't
really
but it does seem like you know there's a
lot a lot a lot a lot of buildup and
then
it's just like everything just goes
crazy at the end you know what i mean
i don't know like your mileage may vary
about that but i mean there's some
really great i mean just
not even like the the image of the house
being buried by sand which is like
creepy enough like if you think about it
because like i said
i could picture this place like in my
head the way he was describing it
and it it almost makes you feel like
you're there like the way he describes
like how it smells and how it feels like
the heat and everything like that
so it was really really evocative like
the writing is really evocative
and uh the character work is fantastic
like i really liked all the
character interactions particularly
between luke luke and india but i also
liked
the character of big barbara who was uh
luker's mom
and she was kind of like this old
southern lady who was drunk all the time
she was very funny
so there was you know there's other
little there's other characters and
there's other little subplots that are
less developed
but i think the three of them were kind
of my favorite characters and i really
liked the scenes and odessa of course is
you know she was a really good character
too so probably four characters
sorry about that the four the
interaction between the four of them i
think was the best thing
but some of the some of the other images
in this and like i said i don't want to
ruin it
completely like if you haven't read it
but there's just really great [ __ ] about
like
the sand forming into something about
this horrific
baby uh if you've read it you know what
i'm talking about like if you really
think about what this [ __ ]
thing looks like it's horrifying
also the description of these
things the elementals and the way that
their eyes are like opposite
they're like black on the outside but
white on this like they have white
pupils but
black the whites of their eyes are black
which really kind of bothered me for
some reason
one line that gets quoted from this a
lot is actually from a parrot
named nails the only thing that he ever
says actually because one of the jokes
is that the parrot never talks
but the one sentence that he says is
savage mothers eat their children
up mary and savage's last name that's
one of the family's last names
but actually the one line that i read in
this and you'd have to like read the
whole book like up to this point i guess
like for this to like freak you out
but i actually read this line and it
like actually made
you know when your blood runs cold that
actually happened like when i was
reading this because i was like
because it just like weirded me out so
much but there's one great scene near
the end
like i said it's a spoiler spoiler
spoiler so if you don't want to like
hear it then turn it off
or skip forward uh you know a couple
minutes or something but there was one
great scene like near the end where
odessa and india are gonna go into the
third house
and you know try to fight it or try to
stop the elementals
and odessa basically says something like
you know oh if something happens to me
or something like that and she says to
india 13 year old girl she says
eat my eyes she tells her to eat her
eyes it's like what i
would just like like weirded out like
thinking about it again and it's like
there was a reason she said that
but just when i because i didn't expect
it i guess when they were just having
this discussion like man we have to go
to this
house and we have to like fight the the
monsters and everything
but just the fact that she just came out
of nowhere and said that i don't know it
just really really creeped me out
you know and like i said there's there's
a reason that it does actually like come
to fruition later on like why
she said that so um this was actually a
really great
book this is a great read um it really
like
put me in the place it's very
atmospheric it's like you can really
and it's it's weird because it's a
southern gothic but it's not
you know it's not like rainy or cold or
dark or anything like that it's very
it's
sunny and hot and oppressive and it's
like set on a beach
um the houses are victorian but it
really is kind of
almost like a daylight horror type of
thing also gave me a little bit
because there's a thing in it too where
where the houses are on this slip of
land
and then after when the tide comes in
you can't
get off of the island because the water
comes up too far like you have to wait
until the tide goes back out again
and that reminded me a little bit of eel
marsh house from the woman in black
which is another book that i
will eventually get to review i have
seen the movie though
but i haven't read the book yet but i do
have it so it did kind of remind me of
that where
you know you're just out on this island
and you can't get off
so this so it's a very like oppressive
isolating
kind of atmosphere and like these people
are kind of trapped here and like
and for a long time you don't really
know what the [ __ ] is going on
in that third house like what the [ __ ]
is it is it a ghost is it
you know you don't really know and like
i said at the end of the book you still
kind of don't really know because
they're not really a solid
monster they're you know what i mean
it's just kind of like a nebulous
idea but i found that a lot creepier
because like i said there weren't any
rules about oh here's you know it's a
vampire we'll stick a
put a stake through a tart and it'll die
so there's nothing like that because
they weren't really sure what they
were so they didn't really know how to
fight them so i really liked that aspect
of it
but yeah if you really like southern
gothic like i said this is very
flannery o'connor there's like you know
william faulconery kind of
uh tennessee williamsey kind of thing
but with a more overt horror
sensibility to it like particularly
towards the end like there's some really
like horrific
imagery that's more befitting of you
know like a
more traditional horror movie i guess if
you want to say that i would actually
like to see this made into a film
i heard that one of his other books cold
moon over babylon might have been made
into a film
but i would have to check again on that
i just remember somebody saying that and
i don't but i don't know if this one
ever has been
but i think this would actually make a
really cool movie i mean i could just
see
like the sand in the house and the
[ __ ]
horror baby and like all this other kind
of [ __ ] i think it would be really
really good
you know but yeah so i'm definitely
going to be
reading more books by michael mcdowell
because
this one was pretty damn fantastic like
i said the same guy that
wrote the initial script for beetlejuice
i believe it was rewritten
because it was too dark the one that he
wrote which if you read this you'll kind
of see like
yeah i get that like i said he might
have done nightmare before christmas too
i'm not
entirely sure but that's what i heard he
passed away in 1999 unfortunately
but they have been uh vannacorp book has
books has released a whole bunch of his
uh
books that came out in the early 80s
that were paper paperback originals
if so now is a really good time to like
catch up on his work because i feel like
there's kind of been a resurgence and
popularity of his stuff can you know
judging by the amount of
reviews there are of his books online on
various other book review channels so i
guess like a lot of people are
rediscovering him which is pretty
[ __ ] awesome
so yeah the elementals check it out